I'm Alexander Rossum the executive
director at the long now foundation
welcome to our first Chabot Center talk
here in the planetarium thank you guys
for coming all the way up here as some
of you know that that come to the lung
now talks that before we do the talks we
often do something called a long short
which is a short film that exemplifies
long term thinking and we were trying to
figure out which one we should show here
tonight and then it occurred to me that
we were in a planetarium and for the
very first time I could request a
planetarium to do whatever I wanted and
so one of the one of the things the
clock of the long now tracks that
actually the slowest cycle that it
tracks if you can bring down the lights
a little bit actually you can bring them
all the way down you don't need to see
me here in the center there is is the
star field and all those pointers are
pointing to the celestial pole Polaris
which is currently at Polaris but the
celestial pole is not always pointing to
Polaris we the last few thousand years
we happen to be in a very lucky position
for navigation where we had a nice
bright star there but that dome of stars
underneath those pointers also turns
once every twenty five thousand seven
hundred and seventy one point five years
in what's called the processional cycle
the axial precession of the earth and so
we actually have a demo of that from
outside the planet
we should kill our projector actually
it's not gonna be possible
excellent
okay so this is the processional cycle
happening you can see the North Pole
they are nicely indicated by the arrow
this is that one processional cycle 20
roughly 26,000 years happening in 30
seconds so it's that it's that 23-degree
tilt of the earth doing a little wobble
but then the thing that I've always
wanted to see is what that looks like
from one place on the planet now the
computer was having some trouble with
this earlier we'll see if it if it
actually pulls it off I think it might
have a deck of millennium bug in it
we'll see okay so we're gonna swing
around first to bring Polaris into view
no one vomit okay so we're looking right
now at celestial North that red dot
which is Polaris and that's if you're
looking at it that's the tail of Ursa
Minor generally and now we're doing a
one-minute full processional cycle this
would be basically you know your shot at
midnight once a night for twenty six
thousand years condensed to one minute
[Applause]
Vegas coming around when the tail of
Ursa Minor is up by that eighty roughly
or about there's Vega right there
swinging by the bright star
so Vega will be our North Star in about
thirteen thousand years if anyone's
paying attention
lovely thank you guys so much and I'll
hand you off to
Alex Whistler the director here at
Chabot to tell you about our evening's
activities thanks everyone
our friends and family from Chabot that
little moment exemplified I was watching
that and I was just thinking this is
exactly why I just love the long now
foundation I had a chance to meet these
folks several years ago in a previous
life when I was the executive director
at Fort Mason and we saw to it that they
have their new home at Fort Mason center
we hope might be a continuing
partnership just a quick commercial on
Chabot I know for some folks at your
first time here or space and Science
Center we see about 200,000 folks a year
we're also the largest publicly
accessible Observatory in the country
and with us with the skies inspiring in
our favor later tonight that the
telescope's will be open for your
pleasure 26,000 years is we like we
started with 10,000 years and we're
getting up to the 26,000 years we use
the five digits for years as you know to
get by the deck of millennium bug and
about 8,000 years so you know this is
zero 2010 but I realize that not too far
out from that then there's going to be
the whatever you call the bug when you
need six digits if we stay with the same
your numeration and then you can start
wondering about what are the chances
that will keep the same new year in
numeration and how long will keep it you
know out of the century
I'm gonna hear a vertebra called star
maker of course Martin Rees has I
recommend it it has this context it is
basically a guy out in a field looking
up in the night sky and then he ascends
into it and joins the life of the stars
it is one of the great visionary texts
and what Martin Rees brings is in a
sense the star maker perspective and
what else he brings is our context in
that context overlapping which in a way
is what the long now foundation is about
we sort of use ten thousand years as a
indicator of a time taking the long term
very seriously
a long time passed in a long time future
Martin Rees lives there please welcome
our speaker good evening ladies and
gentlemen it's a great pleasure and
privilege to be here my lecture is about
the future but I'm going to start in an
old-fashioned way with a text the famous
closing words of the Origin of Species
whilst this planet has been cycling on
according to the fixed law of gravity
from so simple a beginning forms most
wonderful have been and are being
evolved astronomers probe back before
darwin's simple beginning which after
all is quite a complicated situation in
our young planet astronomers trace how
starting from some mysterious beginning
nearly 14 billion years ago atoms
galaxies stars and planets emerged but
in deference especially to Stuart brand
I'd like to describe astronomy as the
grandest environmental science and it
really is because the night sky is the
one feature of our environment which has
been shared
by all cultures throughout all ages
where humans have existed though each
culture has interpreted it in
distinctive ways and as I'll describe in
his lecture our origins lie in the Stars
and our remote descendants may roam
among them my topic today life in the
cosmos fascinates astronomers but it
would fascinated Darwin as well I'm
going to ask what's the future of life
and what's the chance if we discover it
elsewhere I can't claim to be much of a
forecaster or visionary myself and I
always have to say I'm not an astrologer
I don't give horoscopes but my next
picture shows women someone who was a
visionary and many of you recognize him
that's arthur c clarke he said that his
greatest wish was to see the discovery
of alien life sadly he didn't live to
see that he died in 2007 aged 90 but he
did live long enough of course to see
human life venture beyond the earth to
give a bit of history he wasn't the
first person to think about space travel
among his precursors was the great
Newton I gave him a plug Bush his most
distinguished alumnus of my college in
Cambridge I have to say though he was an
unattractive character compared to
Darwin solitary and obsessive when young
vain and vindictive in his old age
so not a nice man but he was of course
the first to understand how in Darwin's
phrase planets go cycling on in their
orbits and he must have thought about
space travel indeed this picture from
the English edition of his Principia is
still a neatest way to explain to
students the nature of orbital flight he
calculated that for the cannonball to
achieve an orbital trajectory for it to
curve in its tragically no
rather than the earth curves away under
it its speed must be 18,000 miles an
hour
far beyond roughest an achievable of
course and the first object to reach
that orbital speed was of course Sputnik
1 only 12 years separated Sputnik and
the first moon landing and the moon
landing was only 66 years after the
Wright brothers first flight and many of
us who recall that expected a lunar base
even an expedition to Mars within 30
years but 2001 didn't resemble arthur c
clarke vision any more than 1984
fortunately resembled Orwell's the
political impetus for manned spaceflight
was lost and only the middle-aged can
now remember seeing live the murky TV
pictures of Neil Armstrong as one small
step in fact my students in England know
that the Americans landed on the moon
just as they know that the Egyptians
built the pyramids both enterprises
seemed driven by equally arcane national
goals but it was a heroic episode and I
cherished this picture assigned for me
by seven of the Apollo astronauts since
Apollo hundreds of astronauts have
circle the earth in low orbit activities
that really seemed neither practical nor
inspiring meanwhile of course unmanned
probes to other planets have been back
pictures of many varied and distinctive
worlds I run through a picture of Mars
you've all seen pictures like this
showing the extraordinary terrain on
Mars here's a big crater there and the
next picture is going to show the place
where those arrows are this is a
close-up of Mars and this is the Phoenix
spacecraft which landed there about two
years ago
and is going to dig up a sample though
not of course yet return it to earth
going further afield the spacecraft have
been to Jupiter here it's four big moons
Europa specially interesting there's his
icy surface beneath which there is
probably an ocean and there's a close-up
of the extraordinary surface one of the
most remarkable feats of space robotics
was connected with Saturn's giant moon
Titan the Cassini mission went to Saturn
and then when it got there a small
European probe called Huygens broke
loose and was aimed to land on Titan the
giant moon of Saturn if we're supposed
to do this this is an artist's
impression of what was supposed to do
open a parachute and land on the surface
and indeed that is what it did on the
left pictures taken all the way down on
the right where it landed now this may
look like rivers and lakes etc but this
is not a hospitable environment these
rivers are rivers of liquid methane the
temperature here is minus 170 degrees
centigrade well I hope that during this
century the entire solar system all the
planets and the main moons will be
explored and mapped by flotillas of tiny
robotic craft far more sophisticated
than the Huygens probe I think we can
predict that but will people follow them
the practical case for sending people
into space gets in my view ever weaker
with each advance in robotics and
miniaturization indeed as a scientist or
practical man I see no real case for
sending people into space at all but as
a human being I'm nonetheless in favor
of manned missions and I hope some
people now living will walk on Mars and
that it will be a long-range adventure
for at least a few humans but of course
this goal is receding
NASA's firm plans now don't even include
a return to the surface of the Moon and
I think one problem actually is that
NASA is constrained by public and
political opinion to be too risk-averse
and therefore expensive the shuttle
failed twice in 120 launches but each of
those failures was presented as a
national trauma causing extra delay and
expense so actually I don't think that
future expeditions to the moon and
Beyond will be politically and
economically feasible unless they are as
it were cut-price ventures perhaps even
privately funded spearheaded by
individuals prepared to accept high
risks perhaps even one-way tickets and
the involvement of people like Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos and others in the high tech
community in launcher development is
surely a positive step and it's surely
not unrealistic to envisage
multi-million dollar projects with
private sponsorship even individuals
could do it as another calibration is
that Formula One car racing involved
leading teams Ferrari and McLaren which
each have sponsorship budgets of three
or four hundred million dollars annually
so in that perspective a ten billion
dollar privately funded or sponsored
project doesn't seem crazy although that
of course is very cheap compared to what
NASA would presently be doing and of
course it's very important to realize
that space travel is dangerous
you must have killed ourselves this
lovely routine and that's the worry I
have with things like Richard Branson's
scheme presented is space tourism which
there again the first disaster will be a
real trauma it's got to be approached in
the same spirit that drives test pilots
Mountaineers round-the-world sailors and
the like and remember that no way in our
solar system offers an environment even
as clément as the Antarctic or the top
of Everest space doesn't offer an escape
from the world's problems as some people
claim
but they could I suppose in future
centuries be self-sufficient groups of
pioneers living away from the earth they
would surely use all the resources of
genetic technology to modify themselves
to adapt to alien environments and the
posthuman era will then have begun and
thereafter evolution would happen on a
technological timescale far far shorter
than a time scale of Darwinian evolution
and of course these Posthumus could
spread still further and machines of
human intelligence could spread further
still indeed whether the future lies
with organic post-humans
or with robots is a matter for real
debate in space exploration there are of
course issues of environmental ethics
would it be appropriate to exploit Mars
as happened when the Pioneers advanced
westwards across the United States is it
okay to send sieves for plows to deadly
modified to grow in alien environments
like Mars should terraforming is
probably thought about seriously or
should the Red Planet be preserved as a
natural wilderness like we think the
Antarctic should be this is an important
debate and the answer I think will
depend on what the pristine state of
Mars actually is if there were any life
already on Mars especially if it had
different DNA testifying to a quite
separate origin from any life on Earth
then there would be widely voiced
insistence that it should be preserved
as unpolluted as possible whereas if
there's nothing there it would seem to
me that it would matter less if we
exploited it and ditto for the moon it
would matter less if we exploited it
well so much for the planets
let's now widen our horizons to the
Stars widen our gaze beyond our solar
system far beyond the reach of any probe
that we can now conceive we can't
foresee going to the stars but could to
be life already
among the stars we certainly learned
enough about stars to understand them
and we understand how they evolved but
we see places where they're born and
where they die here in the famous Eagle
Nebula about 7,000 light years away
there's hundreds of solar masses of
dusty gas condensing into new stars and
new solar systems just as our own solar
system once did and we see stars dying
some die elegantly like this as our Sun
will in about 6 billion years some die
in a less symmetric way this is another
star like the Sun dying and other stars
stars which are much heavier than Sun to
start with die more explosively this
isn't so many people know is the famous
object the Crab Nebula which is
expanding debris from an explosion
witnessed and recorded by chinese
astronomers in the year 1054 ad the
precursor of this was a star about 10
times as heavy as the Sun why do these
far away long ago phenomena affect us
they're very crucial to our very
existence that's because during the
lifetime of the star that gave rise to
the Crab Nebula it was fueled by fusion
of hydrogen to helium helium into carbon
oxygen and the rest of the periodic
table and then when it exploded this
process material was flung back into
space and eventually in about 10,000
years it would all have merged into
interstellar gas and our galaxy is a
kind of ecosystem where gas is processed
and recycled through successive
generations of stars
if this lecture was two hours long I
would explain all this diagram in detail
I won't do that but this just indicates
the various routes where by pristine gas
eventually condenses into stars and the
low mass tiles have long lifetimes they
tie up the gas for a long time
but the high mass stars evolve quite
quickly and then explode and throw the
stuff out again so that new generations
of stars can fall and indeed all the
carbon oxygen and iron on earth and in
our bodies is ash from long dead stars
stars that died before our solar system
formed indeed each of our bodies
contains atoms that came from thousands
of different stars all over the Milky
Way we are the nuclear waste as it were
from the fusion power that makes stars
shine and if you look at it that way
then the cosmos is part of our
environment in the very intimate sense
we wouldn't be here were it not for
these stars which lived and died far
away and long ago stars in themselves
are fascinating as part of our diurnal
for just that reason but if you've now
learned something that makes the night
sky even more interesting that it was to
our forebears many stars perhaps even
most are orbited by retinues of planets
just like the Sun is most are the
planets that we know about aren't
directly detected but they're inferred
and the prime technique is illustrated
in this picture here if a star is
orbited by a planet then what actually
happens is the star and the planet both
orbits their center of mass what's
called the barycenter if the planets
going around in a large circular orbit
then the star goes around in a much
smaller circular orbit the radius being
inversely proportional to the mass and
the star being much more massive moves
more slowly but the small amplitude
periodic changes in the Doppler effect
can be detected by amazingly precise
spectroscopy of the star you can detect
an orbital motion of the star at any
speed down to walking pace that's about
one in 10 to the 8th of the speed of
light very precise spectroscopy indeed
and by this technique by looking for the
periodic wobbles in Stars induced by the
pull of panitch orbiting them several
hundred planets have been found and of
course Jeff Marcy just down the road in
Harvey in Berkeley is one of the leaders
in this search and this is a slightly
old slide this just shows a list of
stars which are known to have at least
two planets by this technique and indeed
one star that's been found to have at
least five planets by this technique now
the evidence about planets around other
stars pertains mainly so far to giant
planets planets roughly the size of
Jupiter or Saturn the chance of our
solar system detecting an earth-like
planet is much harder because they're
put in induced motions of only few
centimeters per second in its parent
star too small to be detected by this
technique of looking for the Doppler
effect but we'd be especially interested
in possible twins of our earth planets
the same size as ours orbiting other
sun-like stars on orbit with
temperatures such that water neither
freezes all the time nor boils and
detecting these earth-like planets
hundreds of times less massive than
Jupiter is a real challenge as I said it
can't be done yet by the same technique
as the big ones are but there is another
technique which can detect less massive
planets we can as we look for their
shadow and that's being done by the NASA
Kepler mission if a planet moved across
in front of a star and we were looking
at the star then the star would get
slightly fainter because the planet in
front of it blocks out a bit of its
light and so if you're looking at
star that it's brightness would behave
as in this diagram here if a planet was
in orbit in the plane of our line of
sight so it moved across it and so this
technique allows you to detect planets
by looking for regular periodic dips in
the light curve of a star now the Kepler
spacecraft which was launched back in
March last year is already finding
dozens of planets not much bigger than
the earth by this technique what Kepler
does is it looks at a patch of sky about
seven degrees across and measures the
brightness of up to a hundred thousand
stars in that field to a position of
about one part in 100,000 and does that
every half hour and accumulating that
data it looks the cases where you see
this slight dimming by a few parts in
10,000 when an earth-like planet moves
across and the hope is that in a year or
two the Kepler team will announce a
number of planets found by this
technique now of course for every one
they find on an earth-like orbit around
a sun-like star you can expect at least
50 times more simple geometry because
clearly you've got to be fairly
accurately in the plane of the orbit in
order to see this effect at all so in a
couple of years time we will have fairly
clear evidence on how many earth-like
planets that are around a typical field
of stars but we'd really of course like
to see these planets directly not just
their shadows as it were and that's hard
to realize how hard let's suppose that
an alien astronomer with a powerful
telescope and say 30 light years away
the distance of a nearby star was
looking at our solar system when the Sun
from that distance would look an
ordinary star
and our planet the earth would seem in
Karl savior's nice phrase a pale blue
dot very close to its star our Sun which
would outshine it by many millions so
you are looking for a firefly next to a
searchlight as it were and that's a big
challenge but if you could detect this
pale blue dot then you could learn quite
a bit about it by watching it because
the shade of blue
seen by the aliens if they looked at the
earth would be slightly different
depending on whether the Pacific Ocean
or the landmass of Asia was facing them
so by watching this dot the aliens could
infer that there were continents the
length of the day something of the
seasons and the climate they might even
be able to infer something about the
atmosphere and it had oxygen and ozone
in it well within 20 years we will be
making inferences like that about
earth-like planets around the nearest
stars and that will involve either large
arrays in space this is a proposed
European project called Darwin as a
miracle project called the terrestrial
planet finder which is rather similar or
maybe even by John telescopes on the
ground this is a design for European
giant telescopes really the truck to
give the scale something like this would
be able to resolve the image of a pale
blue dot near to a much brighter star
well this is what we can expect twenty
years from now to detect planets like
the earth but will there be life on them
we still know very little about this
question I would say we know far too
little to say whether alien life is
likely or unlikely that's basically
because we don't know how life began on
earth we know from Darwin how it evolved
once it got started we didn't know
whether
life on Earth arose by some natural
process or whether it was a rare fluke
like shuffling a deck of cards into
perfect order
you just don't know we would of course
like to find out if there is any life in
our solar system before looking further
and here are possible places to look no
one expects any very advanced life but
it would be very important to see if
there is any vestiges of life here and
if there is as I said early in the case
of Mars we'd like to be sure whether
this life has an independent origin or
whether the life safe from Mars had gone
to the earth or vice versa
and that can be done by seeing if it has
similar DNA but clearly if there's any
life in any of these locations it's not
going to be very exciting or very
advanced life and so we do have to look
further afield to can it's around all
the stars it makes sense I suppose to
focus on other planets which are like
the earth because we know that life did
start at least once in that sort of
environment and so it's sensible to look
at earth-like planets orbitting
long-lived solar-type stars but I think
we shouldn't exclusively focus on that
there is an argument that there are lots
of special features of our earth which
were required some of them are listed
here
I've been booked called rare earth which
has given a list of these things I tend
to feel that that maybe being too
prescriptive as it were because it's not
clear these are prerequisites for life
although we have clearly evolved in
symbiosis with our environment but to
say that life can only exist when all
these conditions are fulfilled is rather
misguided perhaps like saying is that
amazement our legs are just long enough
to reach the ground it's not amazing at
all and so we've evolved to fit in with
this environment but that doesn't mean
that life could not evolve in other
environments so I think we should be
entirely open-minded about where we look
and less parochial indeed we realized
that life is found under fairly extreme
nations on earth in hot springs and deep
underground and of course science
fiction writers have other ideas balloon
like creatures floating in the dense
atmospheres of jupiter-like planets
swarms of intelligent insects nano scale
robots and all kinds of things and
incidentally about science fiction I
tell my students it's better to read
first rate science fiction like arthur c
clarke than second rate science second
rate science may not be true either and
is far less entertaining and to follow
up is your planet i would put in a plug
for the classic science fiction writer
oh that Stapleton who wrote not only
star maker but the book called last and
first men these were two classics and
actually last and first men was one of
the books that inspired arthur c clarke
when he was a child well even if simple
life is common and exists on many times
around other stars
it's of course a separate question
whether it is likely to evolve into
anything we might recognize as
intelligent or complex that's a separate
question of course some people read you
know those who've seen UFOs were being
abducted and in the UK we have the title
of a storm a royal I get quite a lot of
letters from these people and I tell
them isn't it a pity that these aliens
came here and all they did was despoiled
a few corn fields making corn circles
met a few well-known cranks and went
away again and I tend to get these
people to write to each other rather
than to write to me but perhaps someday
we will have real evidence perhaps one
day the SETI searches again being
spearheaded near here will succeed I
think it's very very important that
these are being done because even if the
signal that is detected is very boring a
list of prime numbers or the digits of
pi it would carry the mementos message
that concepts of logic and physics
weren't
limited to the hard way human skulls it
wouldn't prove there was consciousness
out there but it would prove that there
was some kind of intelligence either
organic or some sort of computer now if
there is anything out there which is
sending such signals would we have a
common culture with them well we would
not just mathematics but even if these
aliens live on Planet Zog and have seven
tentacles they'd be made of the same
kind of atoms as we are
they'd gaze out if they had eyes at the
same cosmos as us they trace their
origins back to the same Big Bang so we
would have a lot in common but of course
as you know even if they are around and
miss by star signals will take many
years to reach us so we would have
plenty of time to compose a measured
response if we wished but no scope for
snappy repartee as it were on the other
hand perhaps these searches will fail
earth intricate biosphere may be unique
and that may be disappointing but it
would have its upside because it would
entitle us to be less cosmically modest
with our tiny planets could then be the
most important place in the galaxy
perhaps even a seed from which life
could spread through the entire galaxy
eventually but it's an old saying that
absence of evidence isn't evidence of
absence and of course even if the SETI
search is a V or nothing
there could be intelligences out there
that are leading contemplative lives and
not trying to communicate whether they
could be some that we couldn't recognize
because they're so different from
anything we can conceive there might
even be such things in our solar system
and of course if there are aliens out
there some of them may have insights
which are more advanced than anything we
can pose they may have intelligence far
ahead of us just as quantum theory would
flummoxed a chimpanzee so there may be
aspect of reality
humans were never grasped but which
would be grasped by remote descendants
and may be grasped already by aliens if
they are out there well so much for
possible alien life around stars in our
galaxy
let's now enlarge our horizons further
and I'm going to describe briefly the
large-scale structure of our universe if
it could get 2 million light years away
from the earth and look back we'd see
something like this this picture of
course is you know as Andromeda the
nearest big galaxy to ours
it's a spinning disk viewed obliquely
we're about 100 billion stars are
orbiting around a central hub in the
middle of which lurks a big black hole
and this is a typical galaxy like ours
and our Sun if we could look at our
galaxy from great distance will be a
fairly ordinary star located out towards
the edge orbiting the central hub once
every 200 million years long even by
long now standards well here's another
galaxy
the Whirlpool now astronomers actually
understand a lot about galaxies you
might ask how can they do this because
they can't do any experiments on
galaxies they could just look at them
and and it might be hard to believe that
we can be confident we understand what
they're made of and how they form but we
can do experiments in computer we can't
crash together particles like a particle
visitors can in the Large Hadron
Collider but we can crash galaxies
together in our computers and here's the
results of one such calculation two
galaxies crashing together what's
happening is that the gravity of each
star in wrong acts on the others and
they pull out these sort of tidal plumes
and when these galaxies have settled
down they will have merged into one
single big amorphous bloated galaxy now
we can then look up in the sky and we
see things like that and it's fairly
clear that what's happened here is
rather like in that movie two galaxies
have got dangerously close and each has
pulled out a title plume on the other
and by doing calculations with different
assumptions about the masses the dark
matter etc we can firm up our picture of
galaxies by comparing the outcome of
those calculations with things we see in
the sky so that's why there is quite a
substantial basis for our understanding
of galaxies and of course there are huge
numbers available for study this is a
picture of the galaxies within about a
few hundred million light years of ours
they're grouped together in clusters one
thing we know about galaxies is that
they're moving away from us I mean we've
known this ever since the work of Edwin
Hubble here's a heavy smoker as you can
see and he he discovered that distant
galaxies moving away from us and further
they are from us the faster they're
moving indicated by the longer arrows
further away now this doesn't imply we
in a central position the best way to
envisage the expanding universe is to
think of a lattice like this supposing
that you sit on one of the vertices and
all the rods lengthen then the other
vertices will move away from you with
the speed depending on the number of
intervening links the whole network will
expand now that's a good picture for the
expanding universe
if you imagine galaxies or at least
clusters of galaxies joined together by
rods and all the rods lengthen in the
same proportion and the galaxies get
further away
there's no preferred central position
but there's one feature which isn't
borne out by this picture and is better
done by this other Escher picture angels
and devils because when you look a very
long way away at a galaxy you see it as
it was a lot
time ago because lights take a long time
and so if the universe is expanding
you see distant galaxies at a time when
they were close together when the rods
were shorter as it were so what we
actually see if we look back along our
past light cone is something better
resembling this picture here where as
you look further out towards your
horizon you see things more closely
packed together and we can't see very
far back this picture shows a patch of
sky only a few minutes across it would
take more than a hundred patches like
this to cover the full moon in the sky
with the smallest telescope this would
be a blank bit of sky but with the
Hubble or the biggest ground-based
telescope you see something like this
and each of these smudges is a galaxy
many of them fully the equal of our
galaxy or Andromeda looking so small and
faint because of the huge distance and
many of these are so far away their
light set out ten or eleven billion
years ago long before earth formed and
in fact these galaxies look different
from nearby galaxies because they
contain more unprocessed gas that hasn't
yet turned into stars and a lower
proportion of elements like carbon and
oxygen which you can look for
spectroscopically
that's because 10 billion years ago
there had been enough time to process
much material through stars to build up
the heavy elements and therefore even
though the mite on Andromeda be alien
life there may be astronomers under
looking back at us with bigger
telescopes and ours but you can save for
sure that there aren't such astronomers
on these very distant galaxies because
at the time in the light from these
galaxies set out there would not have
been enough carbon oxygen and phosphorus
to make a planet so we know planets and
therefore scanted chance of life well we
look at these distant galaxies we're
looking back to when Universe was about
of its present age and about five or
more times more compressed but what
about still earlier times I did have
time to go through all the arguments but
again as you probably know there is
important evidence we've had for more
than 40 years which is that
intergalactic space isn't completely
cold it's warm to about three degrees
above absolute zero by very weak
microwaves and these microwaves if you
measure their spectrum at different
frequencies have an almost exact
so-called blackbody spectrum indicating
this is radiation that was once in
equilibrium and so this radiation
filling all of space is a relic of when
the entire universe was squeezed hot and
dense hotter and denser the center of
the Sun and as universe expanded this
radiation cooled the wavelength
stretched but it's still around it had
nowhere else to go
and it's this weak background radiation
and we have this evidence and others
which give us confidence in
extrapolating back to the time when
universe was a few seconds old
astronomers are often accused of being
often in error but never in doubts so
you may say how confident can be about
this but actually the evidence for the
universe at one second is in my view as
compelling as anything a geologist could
tell you about the early history of the
earth we've got various fossils which
could be measured very exactly and so we
do have this time chart for the
evolution of the universe and back to
one second or at least a modest fraction
of a second it's fairly well understood
but right back still earlier on it's a
rather mysterious what we know is that
at one second
everything was in his very hot dense gas
now when you are told that the early
universe was very hot and dense at a
morphism structureless there's a
tendency to be rather puzzled about how
from something like that can our present
complex and structured cosmos have
because most people have heard of a
so-called second law of thermodynamics
which says that structure tends to wash
out structure tends to be eliminated
rather than the form whereas our present
universe is clearly far more structured
than the hypothetical early stage which
was almost smooth how can we reconcile
this emergence of structure with this
law of thermodynamics when the answer is
a crucial role is played by gravity
gravity enhances density contrasts as
universe expands a region slightly
denser than average would lag behind as
the universe expands because of the
extra gravity and eventually condensed
out and I'm going to show you a movie
which shows a volume of the universe
starting at the beginning and ending up
now where the expansion is subtracted
out so it's a patch big enough to make
several hundred galaxies it looks the
same size all the way and on the bottom
left you see the time measured in
gigahertz billions of years and you see
that it started off amorphis but density
contrast grow because gravity is
enhancing them and eventually after 30
points 7 million years we get something
which actually is rather like the
structures in our universe and we have
put in to the initial conditions here
fluctuations which are known to exist in
the background radiation and models of
this kind which are shown 16 powers of
10,000 in real time of course they show
that galaxies can have emerged from an
amorphous early universe and of course
each of these galaxies is then an arena
within which stars planets and perhaps
life can emerge we'd like to understand
in full of detail how from these
amorphous beginnings the cosmos evolved
to its present complexities with the
life and planets and there have to be
quite a few requirements in order for
this to happen and I let me give a list
of them first
we've got had particles at the beginning
protons and neutrons you think could
have stars and planets and then we've
got to have the synthesis of the
periodic table in Stars and then can its
forming around later generation stars
and then of course on at least one
planet around at least one star life has
to form and undergo Darwinian evolution
and that evolution has led on at least
one planets to creatures able to ponder
the wonder and mystery of their origins
well what are the key prerequisites in
the universe in order that all these
things can happen I'm going to give you
a list the first thing is that we need
to have gravity if there wasn't any
gravity then structures wouldn't
condense out as universe expands stars
wouldn't pull themselves together but
gravity is very weak force gravity is
negligible between individual atoms it's
negative on where you have say a sugar
cube or something like that it's
negative for an asteroid when you get
something as big as a planet it makes it
round and when it's bigger it crushes it
to make a star so this picture here
shows the various structures and it's
because gravity is so weak that stars
are so big compared to atoms so gravity
is crucial but we also need the parts of
third-ranked equilibrium if the universe
expanded but then collapsed almost
straight away then
nothing complicated will ever happen we
need matter/antimatter asymmetry
we need more matter than antimatter
because if through equal amounts then as
universe expanded and cooled you put all
the na relate and to be lots of
radiation but no atoms left behind
we need a non-trivial chemistry we need
to have a periodic table and that
requires some other tuning between the
nuclear force that holds the nuclei
together and the electric forces disrupt
them we also need stars to form probably
second generation stars because one star
makes heavy elements but then it's got
to May
second-generation stars in order to have
planets and also the expansion rate must
be tuned because if the universe be
expanding too slowly it collapsed too
soon if it expanded too fast then
gravity wouldn't be able to combat the
kinetic energy and galaxies wouldn't
fall so all those things are required
and there must be some fluctuations in
the early universe in order for the in
order for there to be some thing to feed
on the density contrasts the Kapiti
smooth universe would stay smooth
forever
now what Kosmos are trying to do is to
understand and quantify these things and
understand how they came about these
numbers which all are basic numbers of
physics our strength of the forces etc
they must have been imprinted at some
very early stage in the universe we
don't know quite how early but I think
very early indeed in most people's
pictures I like to show this picture
this shows the very early universe and
this is actual size
this is the size of the universe when
it's a trillionth of a trillionth of a
second old and this is a time when it's
thought that many of these key features
were imprinted in it and the physics at
that early stage is very uncertain we
can extrapolate back quite a long way
but when we get back to that tiny tiny
fraction of a second where all these
important numbers were imprinted we
still don't have any firm foothold
because the physics is far beyond
anything we can directly simulate in the
lab or in the accelerator at this point
I'd like to insert a health warning a
hazard which I want to briefly mention
some speculative issues first how big is
our universe well we can see this huge
range of galaxies out to a distance of
10 or 12 billion light years they're
sort of horizon around us but there's no
reason to think that's all there is just
like if in the middle of an ocean you
can the mast of your ship and you see a
horizon around you but you don't message
think the ocean finishes just just
beyond your horizon and the same is
probably true in the universe in the
universe we can't be sure of what
happens beyond the horizon but the
expectation is that there is far far
more to our universe it goes on far
further than we can actually see one
reason for that is if we look as far as
we can in that direction and in that
direction then conditions look the same
to a precision of one thousand a hundred
thousand so if this part of some finite
structure then that structure must be
much bigger than the scale we can
actually see but some theories suggest
that it goes on even further than that
maybe even so far that all combinatorial
options are played out so there would be
somewhere else another lecturer with
similar people in listening to a lecture
but the distance you have to go to find
that replica is hugely greater it's 10
to the power of 10 to the 200 a huge
number so there's no
possibility of seeing that replica
because it'd be far far beyond the
horizon and moreover even this isn't all
because what I'm talking about now is
the aftermath of our Big Bang but some
theories suspect that there could be
other quite separate regions of
space-time one idea is what's called
brain Worlds the idea that there could
be separate three-dimensional cosmos is
embedded in some common four-dimensional
substratum to give an illustration
supposing that you have a lot of ants on
a sheet of paper that's their
two-dimensional universe they might be
unaware of another population of ants on
a parallel sheet of paper so likewise
there could be another universe just
that far away from ours but if that
distance is measured in a fourth spatial
dimension and we imprisoned in our three
we wouldn't know about it that's one
possibility which some people talk about
with a straight face and this is a this
is a cartoon of an idea which is taken
much more surgical eternal inflation we
are in some region showing bottom rights
but that is just one bubble as it were
in some infinite hierarchy so these
ideas are taken quite seriously and if
there are many big bangs
this raises another important question
which is are the laws of physics the
same in all of them they may be but it
could be that some of the laws of
physics depend on how the Big Bang
cooled down it's different at different
ones and that's very important for the
apparent fine-tuning which seems to have
been required in order for our universe
to exist and this is a sort of decision
tree that we hope eventually to be able
to settle how many big bangs are there
one or many if there are many are they
all the same in the physical laws govern
them or some of them difference and if
we have the the right hand thing then we
can say that our universe is governed by
what we think of universal laws but
they're really as it were by laws in our
cosmic patch and could be different
elsewhere and we are in a universe
by laws that allow complexity where
there could be sterile or stillborn
universes which are disconnected from
ours so remember the hazard warning sign
is still on this is still very
speculative if I needed a logo for my
research group I'd choose this and Ora
Boris the image depicts the
interconnectedness of the micro world on
the left and the cosmos on the right the
inner space of atoms and the outer space
of the universe the links between small
and large left and right and our
everyday world of life and mountains is
in the middle it's determined by atoms
and chemistry and there are other links
between left and right on this diagram
we are determined by aftman chemistry
but there's a link halfway up because
stars are fueled by the nuclei within
those atoms and also though I've had no
time to describe it
galaxies are held together by dark
matter which has believed to be some
particles even smaller than atomic
nuclei so the links between left and
right the left is the domain of the
quantum and on the right hand side
Einstein's theory of gravity holds sway
general tivity and quantum theory are
the two great pillars of 20th century
physics but they haven't yet been meshed
together in a single unified theory in
most contexts this doesn't really impede
scientific progress that's because the
domains of relevance of those two
theories don't overlap a chemist doesn't
need to worry about the gravitational
pull between the different atoms in a
molecule conversely an astronomer
doesn't need to worry about the quantum
fuzziness in the orbit of a planet
whistle tanta so so big but if we think
of the very beginning of the universe
everything was squeezed so dense that we
have to worry about both these theories
quantum fluctuations could had shake the
entire universe when it is compressed
and so to understand the very beginning
to understand what banged and why it
bangs were the many big bangs or
we will have to understand the synthesis
symbolized as were gastronomically at
the top here between the very small and
the very large but before leaving this
picture there's a third frontier at the
bottle
neither the very large norther very
small but the very complex and the most
complicated things are we ourselves
we're actually midway on a log scale
between atoms and stars they're big
compared to atoms quickly got layer upon
layer of structure but we're small
compared to stars we're not so big and
we get crossed by gravity and
incidentally we are fairly accurate in
the middle the geometric mean of the
mass of a proton and the mass of the Sun
is 50 kilograms with a factor of 2 of
the mass of most people here and we are
midway between atom and stars and to
understand ourselves we have to
understand the atoms were made of but we
also have to understand the stars that
made those atoms and the problem of this
third frontier is complexity even an
insect with this layer upon layer of
complexity is harder to understand and a
star where intense heat and compression
by gravity preclude complex chemistry
this picture incidentally is the famous
drawing of a flea by Robert Hooke who
was one of the first people to use a
microscope and he published a book and
he was actually a great enemy of Newton
Newton's least favorite Pharaoh the
Royal Society but he was not only great
scientist but a great draftsman and he
produced this wonderful book and you can
imagine the fascination when the public
saw these pictures for the very first
time but even a flea is much more
complicated than the star finally I want
to draw back from the cosmos from what
even may be a vast array of cosmoses and
zoom back closer to here and now to our
planet orbiting a typical star in our
galaxy
I want to emphasize first that even if
there isn't any life out there it
doesn't mean that life is forever a
trivial afterthought in the cosmos
that's because of the vast time that
lies ahead where life can spread from
the earth far away the stupendous time
spans have evolutionary past are now
part of common culture maybe not in
Kansas and a few places like that but in
most places this is a common culture
that we have emerged over about 4
billion years from simple beginnings but
even people who are familiar with this
tend all too often to somehow think that
we are the culmination of the process
and no astronomer could honestly believe
that the reason for that is that the
time lying ahead is even longer this is
a time-lapse picture showing the sun's
origin from an in stellar cloud its
evolution and eventually it'll become a
red giant it's less than halfway through
its life and it's got 6 billion years
before the fuel runs out and then flares
up engulfing the inner planets so the
future of our Sun is longer than its
past and the expanding universe will
continue far longer perhaps forever
to quote Woody Allen eternity is very
long especially towards the end
so any creatures who witness the sun's
demise six billion years from now they
won't be humans Davy is different from
us as we are from a buck this been as
much time for evolution between now and
then as there has been over the past
history of the earth and moreover as I
said earlier evolution in future is
going to be far faster than Darwinian
selection so post human evolution here
on earth and beyond could be as
prolonged is that a winning evolution
just led to us and even more wonderful
and Darwin himself recognizes this he
realized that not one living species
would exist forever and there would be
new species in future so we're maybe
barely at the halfway stage of
evolutionary development finally we're
all familiar with these iconic pictures
of our planet from space Earth's
delicate bars their contrasting with the
sterile moonscape where the astronauts
left their footprints and we've had
these images of course for 40 years an
environmental icon now suppose that some
aliens have been watching our planet
viewing it like that
not just for 40 years but for its entire
four and a half billion year history
what would they have seen well over
nearly all that immense time Earth's
appearance would have changed very
gradually continents drifted the ice
cover waxed and waned successive species
emerged evolved and became extinct but
in just a tiny sliver of the earth
history the last one millionth part just
a few thousand years the aliens would
have seen the patterns of vegetation
altering much faster than before this
signal to start with agriculture and the
pace of change accelerated as human
populations rose and then there are
other changes even more abrupt within 50
years little more than one hundredth of
a millionth of the Earth's age
the carbon dioxide in the atmosphere
began to rise an ominously fast the
planet became an intense emitter of
radio waves the total output from TV
cellphones and radar transmissions and
something else on presidented happened
small projectiles launched from the
planet's surface escaped the bass fear
completely some were propelled into
orbit some went to the moon
some beyond to the planets well if they
understood astrophysics the aliens could
confidently predict that the biosphere
would face doom in a few billion years
when a Sun flares up and dies but could
I have predicted this unprecedented
runaway fever
less than halfway through the Earth's
life even in this concertina timeline
extending millions of years into the
future as well as the past this century
therefore may be a defining moment it's
the first in our planets history where
one species
ours has Earth's future in his hands and
it'll be us who determined what happened
in the future will life eventually
stabilize will it be some spasm and
disaster will some of the planets so
some of the projectiles launched from
the earth spawn new oases of life
elsewhere so those decisions depend on
us this century and so we're the
stewards of this planet at especially
crucial era and I think that's a message
for all of us whether we are astronomers
or not thank you very much
[Applause]
and I like the way you put long now into
such a miniscule short now I got an
amplifier on and yeah could we see the I
want to take you're still here yes
Martin
Martin has been speaking into brightness
and that needs to yeah look people this
is what discovering life in the universe
is going to be like it's been darkened
in the end it turns out there's people
out there laughing all this time you end
on a note of we're stewards of the
planet and you also had a kind of a down
view on well at least the option that
said he won't find anything either
because it's not detectable or because
it's not this yes yes and if it's not
there and we're the only life and we're
also the stewards of it now
how cosmic is that responsibility well I
think it is a cosmic responsibility
because if life or intelligent life is
rare and there are arguments it may well
be then it couldn't be unique to the
earth within the galaxy and therefore
the earth though tiny is especially
precious place but moreover as I briefly
mentioned if that's the case it doesn't
mean that life is forever a trivial
afterthought in the cosmos that's
because it would be possible in the time
lying ahead for post human life either
organic or silicon-based to spread right
through the galaxy there's plenty of
time for that to happen that could
happen in far less than a billion years
and so the life even if now limited to
the earth could be an important feature
of the galaxy in the far future so the
stakes are in a sense very high in that
if we were to snuff out life now
I think he's very unlikely then we
destroy not just ourselves but that
great potentiality and so to give us IT
service analyses supposing that you
clobbered the first fish that crawled
onto dry land it might have been
unprepossessing looking creature but you
would have destroyed the potentiality of
land-based life similarly whatever we
think of ourselves however mr. topic we
are then we should realize that perhaps
we are not the combination wellyou've
you wrote a book in the most recent book
I think is called our final hour and
it's a kind of a will we get out of the
century alive and you seem to feel the
question is quite open I can't tell if
you're a pessimist or a person he was
trying to warn people to be careful yes
well the book which I wrote I entitled
it our final sensory question mark my
English publishers left out the question
mark and then the American publishers Oh
God retitled it up final our sorry which
I thought was well silly title but I
guess it's Americans like instant
gratification and and the reverse but
the theme of the book was indeed that
this century is indeed especially
crucial one because it is the first when
one species ours does have the future
patent in its hands and I had two themes
really one is the familiar one that we
are collectively putting more pressure
on resources in environment because
there more of us will be 9 billion by
mid-century and raised more demanding of
managing resources so that's says we
need to contend with and climate change
etc but also we are individually more
empowered by technology and is also a
greater threat from small individuals
who want to be disruptive because they
will have more power in the future than
now but for both those reasons I did
think that there was a 50% chance of
something as bad as a nuclear war by the
end of a century I don't think we wipe
ourselves out but there could be a
severe setback due to a misuse of
Natural Resources or misuse of of
technology so that was really my concern
but if you asked am i optimist I think
I'm a technological optimist but a
political pessimist in that I think it's
clear that we will have indeed we now do
have available the knowledge to make a
world with far less poverty and sharing
the benefits of globalization but we're
not doing that and as we develop our new
technology then clearly the potentiality
is a grater for loss of the risks of
greater and that is my concern there's
well a long answer I'm sorry about that
question from Peter Schwartz it's a long
time long term fate of humankind
depended upon whether we can exceed the
speed of light and escape our solar
system or are we stuck with nine useless
planets yes well I think it's true that
if you look at the other planets I mean
there's a there's none that would be
habitable in any comfort and
terraforming of Mars and long-term is a
possibility so I don't think that space
living within our solar system is going
to be attractive to more than a few
intrepid pioneers if we look very far
ahead then of course the first pioneers
could use all the techniques of genetic
modification to adapt to their alien
environment and that will be the start
of the posthuman era but also
miniaturized robots could of course
spread far more rapidly than anything
organic and even to other stars would
take a long time but of course if the
human life is irrelevant then then that
could happen and of course the other
idea again from science fiction is to
descend information at the speed of
light but of course we do have to go
more than the speed of light if we want
to go to other parts of the galaxy in
contradiction to human life time do you
see any hope for faster than light I
don't I mean there is
there are hypothetical time machines but
the only one that's been worked out
involves creating a black hole weighing
as much as 10,000 Suns and that seems a
pretty tall technological order and also
if we could make a time machine it would
allow us to go away fast into the future
and in effect to see the speed of light
but his boat allows to go back into the
past we can't go back to the past we
don't expect therefore to have tourists
in the future invading us question from
Jim Kurtz could you comment on whether
the Milky Way our galaxy has been in a
collision well it's it's not been in a
major collision because if if it had
collided with a big galaxy after its
disk formed then the disk would not
survived the disc would be disturbed and
it would end up as a sort of amorphous
elliptical galaxy so there's been no big
collision in the last six or seven
billion years but our galaxy did grow by
the agglomeration of smaller members and
there are small galaxies in orbit around
it falling into it in fact as the
imaginary cloud through the two small
galaxies which are orbiting at the
distance of about 150,000 light-years
and they will eventually merge with our
galaxy so our galaxy's accreting smaller
neighbors but we can say it hasn't had a
big crash like the one in that movie not
in the last seven billion years
certainly not in the last time of the
song we stuff would not allow there to
be a disc I presume there is no other
large galaxy on the collision course
that we know well there is actually as
Andromeda and Andromeda is coming
towards us and it is quite likely that
Andromeda will crash into our galaxy in
about four or five billion years and we
can't be quite sure which we know the
Sun will still be around for that if
life is still around it will be in the
thick of that it will but it won't
affect things very much because the the
gas in the two galaxies will shock and
will merge will heat up but the stars
are so widely spread at the chance of
two stars colliding is very small so
what happens is the sort of phases of
the orbits and the stars will mix up but
there won't be stellar collisions so the
Sun and the planets would be unaffected
by such goodness anything happen quickly
in the course of something like that I
mean they know they don't hit it it
sounds like it's sort of a slow-motion
ballet it is it's happening on timescale
of 100 million years or so the only
rapid things that happen in astronomy
are when stars are evolved and exploding
and then of course we get explosions we
get two phenomena down to a fraction of
a second I mean neutron stars spinning
around at 700 revs per second sending
out flashes every revolution and so
small things like that can who couldn't
change very fast but some of you as big
as the galaxy can't change in a human
lifetime another astronomical question
from one of the remote listeners who's
listening in on their computer Paul
backways what is the theoretical limit
of resolving power for telescopes
assuming no limit to the cost or size if
you could have the biggest of all
possible scopes when I think in
invisible lights if you do it in space
then there's no limit you certainly get
down to much better than microsecond of
course it's the Earth's atmosphere that
stops that so in in the optical and the
x-rays then you could get a micro
arcsecond even nano arcsecond
in the radio there is a limit because
interstellar gas produces a kind of
twinkling at radio frequencies
rather like the twinkling which the
atmosphere produces in visible light so
the radio telescopes there is an image
although it's still and then I was less
than a millisecond but in the optical
there's no limit anywhere near being
achieved in a foreseeable future and so
the problem of
detecting planets around other stars is
that you do need a big telescope to get
the resolution and also need sensitivity
because you have to detect a very faint
objects can it's very close in the sky
to very bright object to start another
astronomical question from another
remote listener Elliot Hoffmann what
cosmic surprises would you hope and
expect to encounter in the next 25 years
or so that would immediately change
human consciousness about ourselves in
natural world the cosmos I suppose you
can run that question backwards what
kind of surprises have we had like that
in the past yes because by definition I
can't tell you what surprises would be
35 years will give us a history the ones
that blew our minds before yes well I
mean I think the detection of neutron
star this 40 years ago the fact you know
if you tell people that there would be
stars so small that they weigh more than
the Sun and can spin it nearly a
thousand Reds per second that's pretty
mind-blowing and black holes were
theoretical construct but we now are
certain that they exist in the sense of
most galaxies and smaller ones were
widespread so those are two big
surprises we have learnt to considerable
surprise that our universe is speeding
up in this expansion not slowing down
which means that as well as the gravity
which is causing the expansion to slow
down because everything exerts two
gravity's pulling everything else
there's some other way we can diffuse
force which is pushing everything away
from everything else and we don't know
what this force is it implies that even
empty space somehow exerts a force which
opposes gravity and that's a really big
surprise which has come about in the
last ten years and I think it's very
important that's the reason astronomy is
advanced so fast is that technology has
advanced technology sensitive detectors
on the ground and in space and of course
computer power to handle the data and do
simulations and of course the field of
planet
and stars I mean first a planet around a
normal star was found by Maya in Geneva
only 15 years ago and now this is a
major field of astronomy a really
fascinating one and so that's an example
of how an entire new field can develop
it in a decade so it sounds like you're
saying if the technology is continuing
to get better as a steady pace or an
accelerating pace then it will turn up
surprises of this well I think it will
and and of course the timescale for
constructing big telescopes is a decade
or so
I mean longer if funding is slow and we
can predict that within 20 years there
will be no they certainly could be a
finding we're available these
instruments that could detect earth-like
planets I mean not indirectly by their
shadows but actually pin pinpoint them
and study the light problem so that's an
example where we can predict with some
confidence what we will be able to do 20
years from now and we can't do but of
course when we do have those instruments
then as well as doing what we can
predict them to they will perhaps
disclose some completely unsuspected
features that's been the history of most
instruments in the past they've in most
cases done what they were supposed to do
but they have also made entirely
unexpected discoveries and I think
that's the wonderful thing about science
especially astronomy as the front is
advanced the periphery gets longer as it
were and more new problems can be
attacked and if I think of cosmology
when I was a student there was big
debate about was there a big bang how
old was the universe etc and all those
debates have been settled and the
questions were now debating about the
first tiny fraction of a second of a
universe and what the dark matter is
made of et cetera couldn't have been
posed back then and that and that's the
signature of a really vibrant and
rapidly advancing science there's a
question along now a question from
Felicity hammer the Royal Society would
you
just recently celebrated is 350 yes
anniversary and and the question is
would you speak to the issue of the
characteristics and attributes of a
long-term institution what does it take
long that foundation well well start
early okay yes well I mean it is to the
Thule Society who started in 1660 when a
group of the amateur gentlemen
scientists gathered to hear a lecture by
Christopher Wren famous now as an
architect but he was then professor of
astronomy at Oxford and he gave a
lecture on astronomy
and they decided form a society and that
society got a Royal Charter and in 1916
60s they met regularly to have
experiments done for them they were they
were a variety they dissected weird
animals they started explosions and they
heard travelers tales and they did some
rather gruesome experiments they did
blood transfusions between dogs and even
from a dog to a man and the man survived
and and so of course health and safety
doesn't allow us to do these experiments
today the Society's meetings have
changed their character but I think
yeah but one thing that happened very
early in the war society was the
founding of the first scientific journal
because scientists of course throughout
Europe they correspond with each other
but then the first journal was set up
and people like Huygens in Holland
published their papers in this one
journal and that was the way information
was disseminated and that's of course
being the model for the way science is
done I think many of us feel that
perhaps the scientific journal is
getting a bit obsolete in the in the age
of the web but it's been the dominant
means of disseminating science and you
know peer reviewing it to accredit what
is to be taken seriously so that's been
something which the society has done but
what society now like the National
Academy of Sciences in this country is
involved very much in all the issues of
policy that have a scientific I mention
I mean things like environment energy
climate bioethics etc all areas where
science a big impact on policy and where
frankly there are too few politicians
with adequate knowledge or understanding
these are all areas where academies have
an important role and often they work
together because lots of these global
problems are really global and they need
to be tackled by scientists warned over
the world and that's why we in the world
you do have a lot of contact
particularly with the American National
Academy of Sciences but with others
simply to try and raise on the agenda
these important issues in particular
those of coping with the crises of the
next half century but its century
because science moves very quickly the
political the government's that you're
being helpful to move pretty quickly
and yet here and there's laboratories
like the Cavendish they've been around
for quite a while doing very fast moving
science how does this mix of fast-moving
content
and durability of institution how does
that point
well it's interesting I think any
durable institution has to change I
think although I mean I'm in University
which is a celebrate hundredth
anniversary but it was not it was not
the same eight hundred years ago as it
is now is it's a work in progress even
today and that's true of any vibrant
institution but I think there is a
certain attraction and extra
responsibility if you are part of the
institution that has history which you
can on the whole admire it does make you
feel that you do have a special
responsibility although the missions of
any society is just like a university
have to change over the decades Robyn
Sloan has a question are there big
questions of large-scale scientific
projects that we amateurs
non-specialists can contribute to
meaningfully what skills should we learn
what gear should we buy or invent
there's large scale science even talking
about it yes any of the Royal Society
perspectives on things or large scale
science what role amateurs have well I
think of course traditionally amateurs
have had a role in subjects like geology
and Natural History but I think the the
advent of the web has had a tremendous
effect in that it allows people to
participate in science to take an
example when a comet crashed into
Jupiter about ten years ago lots of
people watch that in real time on the on
the Internet
and of course SETI at home is an example
where they've been this year millions of
people's involved and based in the UK
deserve protocol Galaxy Zoo which is
asking people to try and classify the
morphology of galaxies and to to help in
the way that in the old days people have
would have studied rare species so lots
of cases where the public can
participate and the internet makes it
much much easier
for them to participate and also of
course the Internet is really level the
playing field between major institutions
in countries like this
and people working in small institutions
in say India Africa because in the old
days if you were in India or Africa then
you've got scientific journals either
not at all or months late whereas now
you get these journals whether you get
the information on the web
instantly I'll give you an example of
the list let me give two cases in
involving India a hundred years ago
there was an Indian Clark called ram
anujan who sent letters to came with
Professor gh Hardy and these were all
kinds of mathematical formulae and gh
Hardy fortunately didn't dismiss this as
some greening scribbler but realized
that the writer of this material had
really preternatural insight into
mathematics and he invited ram anujan to
come and work in cambridge is a very
famous romantic story but the contrast I
wanted to allude to is that in night in
2002 a professor went to students at
Campo in India made a discovery in
mathematics it was a new way of
factorizing prime numbers which is
important for code theory and they put
that on the internet and within one day
20,000 people have downloaded it and
they've been seminars convened in
institutions in many countries to
discuss these results so instant
recognition for Indian students now by
the internet as contrasted with the good
luck which prevented ram anujan
living in obscurity so that's an example
of how the participation in science has
been hugely widened by
well thanks to the internet we had
GenBank that came along and the
peculiarity that people were putting up
new genomic data in half-baked mode
immediately as you suggest and then it
got sort of baked in public by various
people confirming or denying what they
were discovering and so on and suddenly
science flipped from where one became a
specialist and sort of sequestered ones
data and ones theories and who drew into
himself into a science of sharing and it
used to be that the more control you
head over your material the more you got
promoted in science and now it's flipped
to the more you Sharia material as long
as it's good the more you get promoted
in science so that's a flip then you're
describing the rest of this engagement
that more and more people can have it
sounds like we're moving into an era of
a golden age of amateur science it's
like the 19th century only instead of
the gentleman is whatever well it's it's
a amateurs and professionals and
bloggers etc and of course datasets are
much much larger now not just in
astronomy but in genomics and climate
science and all these things are huge
datasets and more and more people now
have the chance to access and download
and analyze I mean you need to have some
sophistication to analyze a large data
set but I think it's very important that
in subjects where data is gathered there
should be some protocol about whether
the discover has proprietorial rights
whether they should be made publicly
available I mean in the case of the
Hubble Space Telescope for instance the
custom has been that the observer has a
data for a year and then it's in the
public archive and that archive is
maintained in the way anyone can use it
to be in debates about climate records
etc which haven't always been kept in a
form that can be made available readily
and understandable by people but that's
terribly important it's important that
the archive should be accessible and
maintained in a standard format because
more and more people are going to want
to check and it's important that they
should now as the Royal Society you've
had to watch over not just your your
previous domains of science but bloody
well everything for five years and you
and I were just did a gathering of 330
scientists at this Sipho camp for a
couple days hit at Google as you scan
across the sciences what do you see
where do you see the action what's going
on well if take it personally what kind
of excite to you that you see going on
outside your own tree is well I mean I
think the biggest trend is advanced in
in computer simulations because I I
should i showed a simple computer
simulation in my subjects and the main
change in my subject has been that we
can do realistic simulations of stellar
evolution galaxy evolution etc and
computer simulations are now invading
more and more Sciences in fact in
chemistry there are some things which
were done experimentally with now can be
done have better by computer simulations
and so I think that's a big trend
because of the hugely rapid advance in
computer power to do simulations and
process large amounts of data and that
cuts across all things I would say but
also I think the much greater openness
of science to to people in all countries
we had a question from david claussen
basically raising the question which is
often raised about computer modeling of
reality is you know the sort of the
climate models said they well the ice is
going to melt in 40 years and then it
didn't annulled it much sooner than that
and people say well why should we
believe anything else about these models
what is wrong about that important
matter are I guess the question I have
is is say what we are what is really
good about models and you started on
that and then also what things to be
worried about about models and what is
the trend or models likely to get
significantly better for a long time as
there are Moore's law of modeling well I
think in a way there is because of the
growth in the speed of power of
computers but nonetheless there are some
problems which is so complicated that no
foreseeable models will be a very
adequate representation of reality I
mean if you think of climate then the
present climate models of course have
two deficiencies one is that they don't
deal with the water vapor and cloud
cover
very well and also they don't have
spatial resolution and what we want to
know is what the climate impacts will be
on particular regions and the models
don't have that resolution and they pay
a long time before they before they do
and I think a similar story could be
told in in other fields that many
phenomena are very very complicated and
even with Moore's law a long time before
the computer but there certainly an aid
to aid to intuition if nothing else you
know when the map is the territory and
it gets very interesting indeed not a
question in a sense that your first
wonderful participation with law now is
to do one of the early predictions for
long bets it's number nine in the list
anything is featured for that reason and
your prediction in 2002 was that by 2020
there will be an event of bioterror or
bio error that causes a million deaths
and we're now about half way along in
that the voting on it there's four
hundred and four hundred people that
think that you're right and four hundred
fifty people who think that won't happen
[Music]
halfway long what do you think yes well
obviously I desperately hope that I'm
wrong in this case but but my concern
really was that biotechnology is
developing very fast and there are
greater risks of error or terror and
also because populations are crowded in
mega cities in the developing world that
is the place where any epidemic natural
one could become catastrophic I mean you
think Natalie epidemics like SARS it was
jolly lucky that didn't get to a
developing world city which couldn't
cope with so well if it did but I think
the risk is that there may be some some
error or indeed some some genuine terror
which if it happened in area where it
couldn't be cope with adequately could
really be catastrophic in 2020 when we
have a in conversation again you've
either won or lost that prediction
suppose the event has not happened would
you then do a next 20 years or would the
prediction of well done the next one
here is it'll happen or is your
expectation that what we're doing is
getting a sort of a non existence proof
here well I mean I think this goes back
to the theme of my book I think there is
a genuine worry that a few individuals
who want to cause widespread devastation
will be able to do it more easily with
new technology and they could in a past
and so there is there is this risk and I
think the genuine tension between
security and privacy in that if you want
to be sure that people aren't
surreptitiously misusing these dual use
technologies then we do need to be
fairly intrusive but I think the good
news is that only the older generation
seems to care about privacy well if you
look what younger people
surely on Facebook itself like then it
looks as though everyone is watching
each other to the extent that we can be
assured that it would be conspicuous if
someone were being too secretive but I
do worry about a few extremists like
echo freaks who think the world would be
better off without human beings and we
know there are some such people some
people are that empowered by technology
could do huge damage and people with the
mindset of those who now design computer
viruses may start doing the same with
real viruses so I think these are
genuine concerns and that's why I I do
feel that it's going to be very hard to
maintain freedom and privacy in a world
where a few people can do far more
damage than they ever could in the past
I detect it very guarded up in this that
you can see a lot of things that can go
wrong
yes but great hope it's they don't yes
you
and
[Music]
you
[Music]